este es uno de los pocos ataques tal vez
el cuarto que ha sufrido la ciudad de
denipro desde que comenzó la guerra el
24 de febrero Esta es una ciudad que no
solamente es la ciudad industrial de
Ucrania sino que se ha convertido en un
centro estratégico especialmente en esta
lucha de Las batallas por la región del
Don base está la ciudad de entrada hasta
esta zona del este por aquí tienen que
pasar muchísimos de los militares la
logística y también todas esas nuevas
armas que están dadas por occidente Esto
hace que esta ciudad se haya convertido
básicamente en ese pulmón que necesita
el don vas para sobrevivir aquí llegan
también la mayoría de heridos que salen
de allí y lo que dicen las autoridades
es que tres misiles fueron lanzados
sobre la ciudad uno habría sido
interceptado y parece que una de esas
partes del misil que fue interceptada
cayó en una parte de esta calle otro
habría caído aquí cerca estas son
edificaciones muchas de ellas
gubernamentales y militares y otra en
una zona industrial de la ciudad que
como decía en la ciudad más importante
de este sector lo que vemos aquí es una
cantidad de militares haciendo la
investigación sobre lo que pasó esta
noche en un momento en que las grandes
ciudades de Ucrania vuelven a ser
atacadas con estos misiles lo que crea
ese sentimiento de que a pesar de que
muchas de ellas vuelven a la normalidad
como es el caso de de Nitro donde hoy
había muchísima gente en la calle pues
no tienen esa seguridad que la gente
piensa